two months since Kovan 19 spread out of
Wuhan Italy is silent yesterday two
Italians were the first Europeans to die
from the virus and as the number of
cases continues to rise past 100 the
north of this country is on lockdown
we and the health authorities were
unable to locate patient zero we still
have not identified this so it is
difficult to make any predictions about
what the diffusion may be the only
concrete and valid measure to be taken
was to close these territories the Prime
Minister has announced an emergency plan
towns in northern regions of Lombardy
and Veneto have effectively been
quarantined sporting events have been
canceled businesses and schools shut and
thousands told to stay at home and as
the country tries to contain the virus
panic has spread and people are
stockpiling some are worried because
they've struggled to buy face masks the
pharmacy here was open and I took
advantage of that because the ones next
to my home finished everything already
some days ago we are not wearing them
it's just a preventative measure in
Milan the famous fashion week has been
in the balance some brands streaming
shows in empty theatres
[Music]
in Venice museums have been shut and the
carnival cut short
panic is more contagious than the virus
and at this point it's been unnecessary
authorities fear the clusters of cases
will spread beyond the north of the
country we are in touch with the
Emergencies unit of the Ministry of
Health and with the Veneto region I
think we will have to take further
measures we will issue a communique we
are obviously concerned but we are
focused and we are managing the city in
everybody's interest there's a fear
factor here two people are on high alert
the number of deaths may still be low
but this is a very real impact Koba 19
is already having in Europe ally
Fortescue Sky News